hey guys it's Justine happy 2023 and
what a wait to start off the new year
with some Apple news now first off we
all figured that there would be an M2
Pro and an M2 Max chip that would be
coming out at some point following the
same timeline as the M1 so guess what
here we are I'm gonna give you guys all
the specs here in a second but all I
know is that the M1 Mac is so freaking
powerful with any upgrades to this at
all is just gonna be so hard to beat and
I don't even think that I can fully
imagine how powerful that's going to be
like on this computer the fans have
hardly ever turned on over the past year
even doing super processor intensive
things and the battery life is beyond
anything that I could have ever hoped
for in a laptop full flights around the
world this thing has been with me
through it all now I've already had
Hands-On with the M2 Chip in the MacBook
airs so knowing how much stress testing
that I put that thing through my
excitement to get a Macbook and a Mac
Mini cannot be contained like I'm kind
of containing it right now but like I
don't want to so now we have two new
Chips the M2 2 Pro and the M2 Max that
you can choose from in the 14 and 16
inch MacBook configurations now while
the M2 Pro chip it comes with a 10 or 23
core CPU and a 16 or 19 core GPU you can
have up to 32 gigs of low latency
unified memory and it has over 40
billion transistors which is 20 more
than in the M1 now in Photoshop you'll
have 40 faster image processing that was
the M2 Pro now onto the M2 Max this
builds off of the power of the pro it
has up to a 38 core GPU double the
unified memory bandwidth which is up to
96 gigs now both the M2 Pro and the M2
Max chips include a faster 16 core
neural engine and Powerful media engine
so for the MacBook Pros we have a 16
inch or a 15 inch I am so beyond
impressed with the power of the 14 inch
because it literally is just as powerful
as a 16 inch but in a much smaller form
the 14 starts at 19.99 and the 16 inch
starts at 24.99 you can choose between 2
two colors the space gray and the silver
which I have here and both sizes can be
configured with the M2 Pro or the M2 Max
chips and with up to 8 terabytes of
storage now much like the previous
MacBooks from last year the design looks
very similar I mean they look basically
exactly like this one they have the SD
card slot they have three Thunderbolt 4
ports it has Wi-Fi 6E and the HDMI
output will support up to 8K also
something that's really cool is the
magsafe charger it's actually color
matched to either the silver or space
gray which I think is pretty neat you
can get up to 18 hours of video playback
and 12 hours of wireless web browsing on
the 14 inch while the 16 has the longest
battery life ever in a Mac up to 22
hours of video playback and 15 hours of
wireless web browsing both models have a
magic keyboard with full height function
key row Touch ID for unlocking and
signing in and making purchases I really
do love having Touch ID and now even
having that on my full size keyboard on
my desktop it's just really something
that I feel like I can't live without
anymore I just wish that my iPhone had
it too soon the Mac Mini is also getting
the M2 treatments now you can get just
the regular M2 Chip with a starting
price of 5.99 or 7.99 with upgraded
storage or the M2 Pro starting at 12.99
honestly getting an M2 base Mac Mini at
5.99 is really kind of hard to wrap my
mind around because that's a really
great price now of course you are going
to need to buy a keyboard mouse and
display to go with that but if you
already have those then you're set you
can choose from an 8 10 or 12 core CPU
and a 10 16 or 19 core GPU you can
configure it to 8 to 32 terabytes of
unified memory and up to 8 terabytes of
solid-state storage now the Mac Mini
with the M2 can simultaneously support
up to two displays while the M2 Pro can
simultaneously support up to three
displays depending upon which chip you
go with it has two or four Thunderbolt 4
ports both have USB a ports HDMI Wi-Fi
6E and ethernet that can be configured
up to 10 gigabits now we've also got a
new homepod announcement there's the
homepod 2nd gen now after discontinuing
this first gen homepod I felt like my
home just became some sort of little
history museum with all my old home pods
just scattered about I love the homepod
so much I have them in almost every room
of my home and my office at this point
so what's new with the second gen first
off the price it is starting at 299
where the first gen was launched at 349.
it has the same S7 chip that is found in
the Apple watch whereas the first gen
had the A8 from the iPhone 6. it has
four built-in microphones compared to
the original having six but it still has
support for far-filled series so you can
access it from a distance the power
cable is also detachable which is so
nice because you couldn't remove it on
the old one the top has a larger backlit
touch interface it's also lighter and a
little shorter the first gen weighed 5.5
pounds and this is only 5.16 it's also
0.2 inches shorter but they did keep the
same width it now supports thread which
is a low power mesh Network that the
first homepod didn't have now much like
the homepod mini which is their newest
one in the lineup this has a built-in U1
Ultra band chip that detects other U1
equipped devices so you'll be able to
quickly do handoff with audio and your
phone calls it's also got a built-in
sensor that can detect temperature and
humidity of the room sound recognition
also allows the homepod to securely
listen for smoke and carbon monoxide
alarms now I already know that I love
the homepod so having a new upgrade to
the one that I already love I'm pretty
sure it will live up to the expectations
but I will say I was kind of hoping that
they create something with a screen
along the lines of that kind of like how
Amazon Alexa has their Echo devices so
it will be interesting to see if they
ever do decide to go that route I feel
like if they would end up doing
something like that it would probably be
an entirely new product instead of just
building off of the homepod like maybe
no pod maybe just like home like an
iHome I don't know anyway I'm super
hyped about the announcements it is kind
of difficult sometimes covering these
things because cosmetically all of these
devices look very similar to previous
ones so sometimes when reviewing these
it's hard because it looks exactly the
same so really the only way to show you
the differences is by showing the
performance I'm already blown away by
what Apple has done with apple silicon
so I can't wait to get my hands on one
of the new Macbook Pros you guys know
that I can't wait and of course I did
end up specking out a full 16 inch with
the 96 gigs of RAM I mean that is a
freaking dream come true like I mean my
day-to-day things even just editing 8K
video like that's it's just wow if you
guys haven't already please subscribe
I'll be posting of course reviews of all
of the new Apple products don't forget
to like comment and let me know what
kind of videos you'd like to see I would
love to try some new things here because
I feel like review videos kind of seem
so repetitive so if you guys have any
ideas or things that you'd like to see
things that you'd like to be tested I
would love to hear them in the comments
below I also did send a tweet out and
saw some really great responses to some
videos that you guys would like to see
so hopefully we'll be making those here
shortly thanks again for watching you
guys are awesome I'll see you later bye
[Music]